[Music]
an ancient creature is lurking in the
ocean
it's double the size of a T-Rex
its gigantic Jaws could crush a car and
now it's on the hunt for you
Megalodon sharks haven't existed for
more than two million years but today
we're bringing these apex predators back
to wreak some havoc
now some people believe Megs never went
extinct instead they're hiding in the
deepest depths of our oceans
the Mariana Trench
well if the Megalodons were still around
that would be the last place you'd find
them
that's because these prehistoric tyrants
hated cold water they preferred the
warmer Waters of the Mediterranean and
the Caribbean
they also loved to explore the coasts of
Australia and California
if these Predators were around today
they might seriously ruin your Beach
vacation
but if they spotted you swimming in the
ocean
they wouldn't just attack right away and
this has to do with your size
Megalodon sharks were gigantic
at least 16 meters in length so they
needed a lot of food
scientists estimate that Megs ate about
1200 kilograms of fish every day
to hit their caloric intake goals they
even dined on sea mammals like whales
and dolphins
so you puny human might not be worth
their attention
unless you were hanging out with a group
of friends now that's a worthier snack
and the Megalodon could devour you and
your friends all in one bite
oh and let me tell you these Predators
had gigantic sharp teeth
each one of the Megalodon's teeth was as
big as your hand and unlike us humans
Megs kept producing new sets of teeth
every week or two
in their lifetime they'd go through up
to 40 000 of them
if they never went extinct you could
find those all over the ocean
you could find some huge carcasses too
but that wouldn't happen all too often
scientists think that megalodons had a
lifespan of up to 100 years
but you know even if humans weren't on
the Megalodon's menu
their enormous appetite would hurt us in
other ways with this huge new predator
in the oceans there'd barely be any fish
left for us
and not because their boats wouldn't
catch anything but because they would
and then megalodons would hunt them down
attack and eat everything in sight
it's not clear why megalodons
disappeared these millions of years ago
but it could be because the oceans got
too cold for them well now they'd be in
for a treat because our oceans are
warming up
thanks climate change
megalodons would Thrive and reproduce
you see more and more of these Predators
showing up
they'd be disrupting our shipping
operations and potentially bringing an
end to the cruise industry
but eventually they might die out once
again after they ate whatever they could
in the ocean and had nothing more to
feed on
or maybe the rise in global temperatures
would hurt us so much that we'd be the
ones to go extinct
but that's a story for another what if